on sait les difficultés en france
lorsqu'on aborde le problème de la
fonction publique et bien en angleterre
le ministre des finances vient
d'annoncer la suppression de cent mille
emplois dans les ministères dans les
quatre années à venir suppression pour
permettre des embauches dans d'autres
secteurs de services publics comme la
police les hôpitaux qui en ont un besoin
réel arnauld miguet à londres ce matin à
whitehall dans le quartier des
ministères
le moral des fonctionnaires n'étaient
pas au beau fixe et pour cause ils
viennent d'apprendre qu'il y à du
licenciement dans l'air la plupart
souligne le devoir de réserve
d'autres sont simplement démoralisés
c'est normal et vous pensez perdre votre
travail
on verra probablement
deac la fonction publique cette année
était de frapper gordon brown puissant
ministre de l'économie et des finances
était lui tout sourire hier avant son
annonce au parlement sur les 517 milles
emplois de la fonction publique sans
4000 postes seront supprimés d'ici 2008
par mesure d'efficacité
d'où la grogne des intéressés on fera
tout ce que l'on pourra pour empêcher la
réforme et défendre nos membres et le
service public et on fera la grèce même
gordon brown essayé hier de faire avaler
la pilule en annonçant des
investissements supplémentaires dans les
services publics éducation transports ou
santé qui en ont grand besoin
certains fonctionnaires auront même
droit à une formation professionnelle
pour changer d'emploi et être redéployés
le message est clair moins de
bureaucratie mais plus de policiers
d'instituteurs de médecins ou
d'infirmières dans cet hôpital par
exemple beaucoup d'observateurs souligne
surtout que c'est un programme pré
électorale on vote dans un en
grande-bretagne